when i think of my ties i i think of my
husband's favorite drinking partner i
don't necessarily think of amy trask the
princess of darkness amy what is your
drink of choice do you drink at all or
are you are you a sparkling water kind
of person oh no i'm not a sparkling
water kind of girl i do like sparkling
water and i really do need to drink a
lot more water because people say you're
supposed to but i don't drink enough
water um i don't know that i have a
drink of choice but i do enjoy a beer
yeah okay because we're celebrating here
today it's mimosa friday in the rich
eisen show we try to have a good time
when i'm here because they have to deal
with rich all the time and cara
henderson snead is here she spent the
last hour with us we're talking about
the parade the behind the scenes things
and what have you all that has to do
with the rams so we thought we'd
celebrate a little bit
well i've been i've just i've thoroughly
enjoyed listening to the two of you talk
and
the last bit that you talked about
really resonated with me and speaks to
the journalists and the women that you
are um coaching players up when they say
something or a coach says something and
you take that moment to say wait a
minute wait a minute i don't think you
mean to say that that just speaks to the
women you are to the humans you are to
the professionals you are that really
resonated with me um and by the way i
did know that it was mimosa friday and i
kind of thought the rich eisen show
might have had a mimosa delivered to me
so i could drink it while we're talking
but there hasn't been a mimosa knock on
the door oh man that is a that is a
missed opportunity didn't go through
that's our bad amy missed opportunity
i'm sorry amy
did al drink mimosas
what was al's drink of choice
not a not a drinking man i can't say to
you that he never ever drank i don't
know that to be the case i do know that
in the almost 30 years that i was there
never had a drink in my presence even
when we were out to dinner with groups
of people and other people were enjoying
wine or whatever al didn't drink i love
that and but he did have a specific meal
right that he always had
in his office at the end of every day
uh there were a variety of specific
meals there were times he would eat x
times he would eat why
and you know i will say that my absolute
favorite uh meal story about him is if
you will is how um really kind and
caring and and he was and how he went
out of his way for me i'm a vegetarian i
don't eat anything that was alive and
but people immediately say but amy
plants are alive i think we know what i
mean
and when we would be out whether it was
a league meeting or a business dinner or
you know a social function he always
went out of his way to say do they have
something for amy um and i just that
really resonated with me that's awesome
how about a john madden story for us
tell us about john madden's story as you
know and all of you know uh the john
madden memorial was this past monday
what was your favorite john madden story
uh well i this may stun you stun you um
i behaved poorly at a madden mariucci
bocce tournament every year steve and
john teamed up and had a bocce
tournament the proceeds of course went
to charity well i've never played bocce
in my life i've never even heard of
bocce until this tournament but of
course we all jumped in cars every year
we went over to the bocce tournament to
support john and steven their efforts
well never having played bocce not even
knowing what bocce was one year i
decided you know what i'm going to coach
our bocce team i'm going to be the coach
so our players were all there and i
decided i would coach them well we won
we won the whole damn tournament we
knocked madden's team out and they were
i think the reigning champs well i went
running around the court with my arms
extended straight in the air over my
head kids tell me that's called flexing
well i went running around the court
like a little nut celebrating and i mean
i'm like running up and john was there
i'm like running by him with my hands in
the air you know you're behaving poorly
when willy brown
you know comes running over and puts his
hand on your shoulder and he's like calm
down amy calm down but i didn't calm
down
i love it
a couple days later i picked up the
phone and i called john um because i
started thinking about the expression on
his face when i was doing that and i
told him how magnificent the tournament
was and i said look i'm sorry um
about my behavior at the end it was a
bit over the top well he let me know it
was a bit over the top and he let me
know in no uncertain terms that my
apology was due and owing which it was
and he accepted it and we went on to
laugh about it for many years so what
did he say to you i need i need more
insider information i think he i think
it just sounds like he was upset he lost
he was probably the reigning champ
you you guys i was behaving to to say
that it was poor sportsmanship is an
insult to poor sportsmanship i was just
reveling in our win
and i kind of loved it but then the
expression on his face if looks could
kill and you know it it really would
have killed so i called him up mostly to
thank him for you know the tournament
and the money they were raising and you
know to talk about that and to say oh by
the way you know if i overdid a little
bit sorry about that and he said yeah
you overdid a lot and we laughed about
it and we went on from there but it
became a source of humor for us for many
years amy's on my team
that's what i know i've just learned
that amy trask is competitive as i am
and like when you when you win like a
really great like horseshoe
match or something that's the way i
behave
absolutely here's to us then but you
know when willie brown
is the king of unsports i mean i
remember once this is really bad but it
was way way way way before cte was an
issue or
but like i early in my career willie was
one of our coaches and we're playing a
game and we knocked the opposing
quarterback out of the game not with a
head injury not with a serious injury
but we knocked him out of the game and
willie brown is standing on the sideline
and he's looking at the opposing team
and saying rolling off roll them off get
another get another so when willy brown
tells you you're over the top you know
you're over the top listen i'm not gonna
lie when i beat my 10 year old in tennis
i give a fist pump well you take that
cooper
your mom who's your mother i am you must
be so horrified so that's a little
window into my motherhood everybody
that's awesome that is absolute i wish
you could see the smile on my face you
should that's great yeah you can't you
can't let them show that to you you
can't let them win
and you're welcome embarrassing your
children you're really not doing
something right oh my gosh we
i'm gonna bring the mimosas to you we're
gonna go on a tour oh that'll be good we
should we should do a tour we should
well amy you know what i said was
there's three women on a tv show at the
same time i mean they with the police
may be at the door and even though we
can take the show on the road broken the
internet yet yeah by the way
you know look this is personal business
and obviously you need not answer this
to anyone but i'm just saying when i'm
listening to the fact that rich is in
hawaii and you're doing the work for him
i think you might need my representation
well you do represent my dogs
you do represent my dogs and dogs
everywhere on the internet one of my
favorite
reasons that i actually look at your
twitter you know i'm not allowed to have
a twitter because i'm a little bit of a
hothead oh i went after some people this
week i don't usually but i did yeah you
gave a couple goons some platform i was
gonna say oh no i don't you like one of
them already had a blue check and just
needed to have that blue check like
smack him upside the face yeah how'd
that feel
i mean every once in a while like i
usually don't engage the the goon
machine but every once in a while
you just you just gotta do what feels
right in the moment exactly
i will tell you guys though i insist in
my twitter village that when we disagree
with one another we do so agreeably and
very very relatively i should say
relatively few times has there been
someone who's responded to me in a
really really nasty manner and when i
reply back i say look go ahead and
disagree with me we can have different
views but you don't need to be mean and
of course i sound like an eight-year-old
saying don't be mean to me but i'll
write back and with you know only one or
two exceptions the people to whom i've
written that have written have have
written back and said you know what amy
you're right we can disagree with one
another but i didn't need to be nasty
about it i could have expressed my
disaster
so we're gonna change the world through
twitter
i agree through twitter 140 words at a
time
right
nobody ever apologizes opinions are fine
different facts not so much no that that
usually gets me
amy trask here on the rich eisen show
suzy shuster kara henderson snead with
me since you bring up social media we'll
let's just switch really quick for one
or two housekeeping things
what's your take on the kyler murray
situation in arizona of a player
scrubbing his instagram
cardinals kind of playing back this tit
for tat what's your take on this as
someone who ran a team
well for one of the one of the first
people that i thought of when i saw all
of that going on was herm edwards who
would just say don't hit send and i
realized in this instance it wasn't
hitting send but it was scrubbing
accounts deleting things the point being
take a moment think about what you're
going to do on social media whether it's
by commission writing something or
omission deleting someone
um
be careful take a deep breath because
all of that is picked up upon and it
resonates and look we don't know what
the future is going to be for kyler and
for the cardinals i have thoughts on
that as well but i would just say to
anyone and this includes everyone in my
village real life twitter otherwise
be judicious in what you do on social
media because it resonates and it can
resonate in a manner in which you don't
intend it to resonate or maybe you do
intend it to resonate but you really
shouldn't so what are your thoughts then
well my thoughts are as to um the team
they've got to ask and do what whenever
i hear of a team that is thinking of
moving on for a quarterback thank you
amy
you know i'm not suggesting that arizona
is thinking about that but should
arizona think about that should green
bay be considering that with respect to
aaron and we all know it's being
considered in any number of ways should
any team ever be considering moving on
from a player you've got to ask yourself
the question and do what and if you
don't have an answer to that or the
answer you come up with is not at a
minimum as good as but hopefully better
than the status quo then what are you
doing you know throughout my years in
the league i would hear from fans you
should get rid of this quarterback him
by the way as if that was my choice you
know there's this guy named al davis you
might want to talk to him
but you know anytime i would hear a fan
say you need to get rid of this player
you need to get rid of this coach you
need and do what you've got to have a
plan look i had a terrible terrible um
incident on a horse many many years ago
and the reason i raised that is when
everything got resolved and i was fine
and the horse was fine and everything
was you know calmed down someone looked
at me and said amy
you have to have a plan
and she was right
she was also eight years old at the time
you know we really do need to listen to
eight-year-olds more but my point is you
gotta have a plan you can't just say i'm
going to move on from a quarterback
without asking and answering and do what
and as far as kyler goes he needs to
also recognize that while a player may
sometimes think the grass is greener
elsewhere it may not be maybe it will be
but it's not always greener elsewhere i
mean isn't that what we're seeing right
now playing out in front of our eyes
with aaron rodgers and green bay and
possibly denver and
uh myriad other quarterbacks out there
that are seeing the grass and thinking
does it look less or does it look great
is that wild to you amy that there are
this many
franchise level quarterbacks that are
being moved around it's so different
than the way that it used to be uh it is
different and of course it's because the
structure of the collective bargaining
agreement is different oh the world is
different i mean but you're absolutely
right um it is very very different in in
many regards and i think i've stopped
being surprised i mean and i say that
and you know an hour from now something
will surprise me but you know
there is a lot of movement
um more than there used to be and it's
not always beneficial to the team or to
the player i think there's more movement
than there sometimes need be essay aaron
rodgers
i've said it on air i'll say it again
now i wouldn't be stunned to see him
stay in
green bay you know we hear all of this
every year where is he going is it
denver is it here is it there i wouldn't
be surprised if it's remaining in green
bay well they brought in his
quarterbacks coach for a reason right
they they brought him back to work with
him well and he loves matt laflore those
two are you know
like after their initial i think thing
where you know he's like well no i'm
gonna audible and matt's like that's not
what we do and he's like well that's
kind of what i do and i've been around
for a while like they really do have a
have a close and tight relationship so
that's interesting now i have no idea
what was said after the whole thing that
occurred last year if there was a
backroom deal made that i'll do another
year or or how it went you know we don't
know that and and that's what you learn
being on this side of the equation is
what people think they know and what's
actually true right amy it's like the
iceberg effect like people only know 10
they don't know the 90 that's going on
behind the scenes so we don't know what
was what was agreed to do you think that
they should have told him that they were
going to draft
uh jordan love
oh i absolutely do but i want to say
first that i wish i could jump through
this phone line right now and throw my
arms around you and give you a hug and
toast you with a mimosa you know the one
that didn't get delivered to me
i'll drink one for you that's our bad
amy i'm sorry it's actually chris
brockman's bad personally but that's
really amazing i don't want to blame him
you just said that which so many others
um really most don't acknowledge which
is we don't know everything and i love
you for do i love you for a lot of
reasons but for doing that for stating
that which is you know a lot of times
people are offering this view and that
view but they need to say going in that
which you just said which is we don't
have all the facts we don't have all the
information so we're trying to gather as
much as we can and make informed
decisions without all the information uh
as to the jordan love
question absolutely positively uh when
the chief drafted patrick mahomes
they picked up the phone and they called
alex smith ahead of time and said look
we just want you to hear this from us
directly this is what we're planning to
do in the draft uh if he's available to
us this is what we want to do and they
had the respect for him
um and the the collaboration with him to
let him know ahead of time and you know
what when they won the super bowl
the first or one of the first people
that patrick thanked was alex smith for
being the teammate and the mentor he was
and for helping him in every way he
could and it is my view that the chiefs
created the environment i'm not
suggesting alex wouldn't have done so
otherwise by all accounts he would have
done so for anyone but the chiefs
cultivated that environment of
cooperation and collaboration there is
absolutely no reason in the world why
aaron needed to learn that with the rest
of everybody on television especially
not aaron rodgers right like we all know
enough about him to know that you know
like disrespecting him in that way like
trust needs to be built with him and so
to do that just it was just very
interesting to me but i i think that
about you know being on this side of the
equation you know you and i kind of
flipped you know flipped around and so
you get to see both sides of it but
being on this side of the equation what
you really learn is
that players may not always like what
you're going to tell them
but but when you're open and
communicative with them
and you respect them and they don't feel
disrespected like trust is the biggest
thing that you build with players on
your team and they may not like it like
les is very good about having very hard
conversations with people but they
always appreciate it i i agree with you
absolutely positively entirely in all
regards and i will tell you a story in
that respect
we were it was the day of the draft you
know the first day of the draft this is
one year while i was with the team uh
one year in particular and it was we
were getting ready to make our pick but
to effectuate what we wanted to do we
were going to trade a player on our
roster and al davis picked up the phone
and called him personally to deliver
that news he didn't assign it to someone
else he didn't let someone he said no no
no no before we announce this trade i'm
calling this player personally and this
was not a quarterback this was not you
know a player who was in the spotlight
this was one of the men on the 53-man
roster a good player an important player
um but he wasn't what fans would refer
to as a celebrity or a star in that
regard but al wanted to tell him
personally so when you talk about
respect and delivering news a player may
not wish to hear but delivering it
personally it makes all the difference
amy i had to walk out of the room
when les
was calling jared goff
last year
i couldn't stay for it
he's like i'm making the call and and
you know i was like i
i have to leave like you know that's the
part of it you know when you
when you fall in love with these people
you know it's it's really hard when then
the business part of it comes into play
and you know i can't say enough about
jared goff and let's be clear he was one
of the first people to text the
whitworths
when we made the super bowl so
sometimes it's the worst conversation
ever but you have to have it and amy
you've been on the on both sides of all
of these conversations for so long and i
know that you were loved for your
directness not only being the princess
of darkness because i wish i had a
nickname like that but that was all you
do you just don't know
because nobody will ever have as good a
nickname as princess of darkness so i'm
just gonna it's it is brilliant listen
and i i tell stink this you know stink
okay that's a good nickname but it's not
princess of darkness because in my view
and of course i'm saying this with a
giant smile on my face because everyone
should love their nickname but in my
world view there is no greater nickname
than princess of darkness and you should
be very very afraid of me well i am so
afraid of you all five foot three of you
i'm scared to death when i knock on the
door later and there's a note that says
p-o-d um answer the door it'll be me
with champion and o.j okay okay i'm come
on over you guys i'll be here amy thanks
again
thank you hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here